ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Discovering
enterprise data sources
is a time-consuming
challenge and is usually
based on tribal knowledge.
Data discovery is now made
simple with Data Catalog.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Data Catalog is a fully managed
and scalable data discovery
and metadata management service
that empowers organizations
to quickly discover,
understand, and manage
all their data in Google Cloud.
I am Anita Kibunguchy,
and today, we'll
be tackling data discovery
with Data Catalog.
Data discovery usually
starts with a question.
What's the slowest link
in our supply chain?
How many of our
retail customers are
within driving distance to
our competitors' new flagship?
Where do monarch
butterflies stop
during their annual migration?
Unfortunately, users
spend an incredible amount
of time and effort discovering,
validating, and getting access
to the correct data sets
and sources, and to be
able to answer their questions.
But thanks to the
same technology
that powers Gmail and
Drive, Data Catalog
provides a simple and
easy-to-use user interface
with powerful, structured
search capabilities
to quickly and easily
find data assets.
So now, let's see it in action.
Using the search bar at
the top of Data Catalog,
you can conduct a
search of all your data
assets across BigQuery
and Cloud Pub/Sub.
We'll be adding
additional data sources
in the future,
including on-prem.
Data Catalog also
provides faceted search,
allowing users to
search by type, column,
and tag across literally
millions of data assets.
Beyond the search bar, you
can view popular tables,
which span the most queried
and viewed BigQuery tables
in the past 30 days.
You can also explore Pub/Sub
topics, as well as tables
and views, and
actually get started
with creating tag templates.
The beauty of Data Catalog is
that it has built-in access
level controls which honor
source ACLs, allowing users
to get started with data
exploration in a seamless
and more secure way.
Thank you so much for watching.
And please check out
our Data Catalog videos,
or visit our website
to learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]